with bodies now removed from the streets
of bucha video from ukraine's state
emergency service shows workers removing
unexploded shells
but authorities expect to discover many
more bodies in keeves suburbs in the
coming days
i don't know exactly what happened to
that house says this man in a nearby
town but there are people under the
rubble there
russia claims the deaths in bucha were
staged after russian troops left at the
end of march despite the mounting
evidence these satellite images show
bodies on abuja street almost two weeks
earlier an analysis by the new york
times shows they were lying in the same
positions when the russian troops left
and this drone video appears to show the
moment a cyclist was gunned down the
video matching the same position where a
body and a bike were later found
british prime minister boris johnson
attempted to break through russia's
propaganda machine with his own
bilingual message condemning vladimir
putin he knows that these crimes betray
the trust of every russian mother the
horrors of bucha triggering what is now
a fifth round of sanctions from the
european union clearly in view of events
we need to increase our pressure further
we will impose an import ban on coal
from russia
worth 4 billion euros per year the eu
also sanctioning russian shipping plus
exports of wood seafood and liquor but
not russian oil or gas europe simply too
reliant on those imports for now
reports from the czech republic say its
government is now the first to send
tanks to ukraine we currently
are in need of heavy weapons like planes
tanks
armored personnel vehicles ukraine again
warning that russia's retreat from kiev
is only intended to redouble the force
of its invasion in the east redmond
shannon global news london